[Music]
welcome to another episode of vm end to
end a show where we have a vm skeptic
and a vm enthusiast get together and
hash out all things vm related brian
thanks again for coming in and uh
spitting knowledge at me i'm so excited
about this one disc just discs
yeah you would i don't understand this
i've been trying to figure this out for
three episodes now what is it about disc
that is so exciting for you i think part
of it for me is that um
you know i think almost all useful
systems have to store their information
somewhere right like your system has a
memory and like you care about the data
and
you know that most of the time that's on
a disk somewhere or ends up on a disk in
the end um and so i think you know for
me
it's where systems get real
and
okay
that's the big deal
i can see that it's a fundamental unit
of computing and so that's what's
exciting yep and you know on that unit
you know we think of them as you know
physical hard disks or maybe an ssd
um but let me turn this back on you like
in the cloud and compute engine what do
you think a disc is
okay all right going back to the slice
of a data center model
to me a disc would be a bunch of pieces
from real physical machines spread out
over a data warehouse or data center
pulled together and presented to me the
user is one logical disc that i can work
with and operate on exactly
spot on
uh yes
that is exactly it um you know
and
you know in fact you know some of the
some of that so it's a network attached
disk right you know it speaks of a
protocol and even physical disks these
days speak a packet protocol so sata is
serial ata
and they talk about the block so here's
a block of data or give me that block of
data and you know our speaker you know
similar protocol but over the network
to a group of disks
so
i guess what is it that's exciting about
that and especially the the network
attached part because like when what i
care about
is performance i care about backups and
scalability i care about reliability
more so than a fundamental unit of
computing
where do these disks kind of sit in
relation to those yeah um okay this is a
this is a meaty question so i think i
think actually let's talk about each of
these uh in you know in a row so
um
performance to to start
um
i i think performance is kind of tricky
like what does it mean to be fast
and i think there's actually
two different parts of that for discs
like one is kind of throughput like in a
bulk how much data can you copy over a
certain amount of time
and the other is latency so how quickly
can you get a response back to a
specific question
um right and it feels like a
a physical disk is going to be faster
than that because i don't have to
communicate over a network like that
seems like common sense to me and
i agree it seems like common sense and
it's true for one and not for the other
and
it's kind of weird why that is so um as
as physical discs are getting faster
over time
um the
sorry as they're getting larger and
faster but the they're getting larger
faster than they're getting faster in
the so like there's more and more
capacity on the disk and the
the window to read and write that is not
getting as big as fast so
if you're talking over the network to
hundreds or thousands of disks
you can actually get more overall
throughput so
the throughput side is an area where we
are
actually faster than a single physical
disk
um but sometimes there is a little extra
step there so if you need the absolute
lowest latency
read
you might need something faster so we
have a product local ssd to do that
and that's basically just literally
attaching a very fast hard drive to a
machine yep it's a it's a physical ssd
on the host um that we are running your
vm on
and so
okay so that seems to me like uh i come
from video game programming so is this
something i would use for maybe an
inventory management system something
like i i recall items in inventory often
is that a good fit for this it would
seem like it um but i think in this case
probably not so
the
the local ssds are actually intended for
temporary storage because they are
mapped to this physical host and you
know we want our vms to be long lived
and you know able to move around so
there there are cases where you know
we can't have the data live as long as
you might like on a local ssd so they're
best fit for things like caches or
data that can be regenerated by
processing or
you know transcoding workloads or things
like that
intermediate calculations in math or
vectors or not okay absolutely that all
right that makes a lot of sense then so
then what
what does google computer what does
compute engine offer when it comes to
different types of physical disk or
different types of pds persistent disks
yeah um
i think the
there are multiple different types and
i'm probably not going to go into all
the details but the the basic breakdown
is an area that i think you didn't hit
here and that i think does matter to
everybody and that's cost
um oh that's a big one yeah so um
it basically boils down to a price to
performance ratio you know so like when
you have a workload that is really
performance sensitive um there are
versions of persistent disk that can can
hit that and they tend to be a little
more expensive and if you've got a
workload that is
you know mostly about storing
information and you don't access it that
often you know there are less expensive
uh modes of pd to do that
and that makes sense to me um like if i
was a small business owner i might not
need the speed and skill that say uh a
google a company like the size of google
would operate at
and so then sorry to not get into
but
like to that point i think
lots of workloads need both as well or
like systems need both you've got a
long-term storage and a and a high-speed
portion as well
okay that's actually a really good point
so then okay talking about systems and
like you said like this in systems in
the wild might need two types of disk
what about backing up these kind of
systems that are in production uh do
these virtual network disk actually help
with reliability or backing up
data a lot absolutely so um you know
it's this like you said it's this
logical collection of of blocks right so
in many ways i think it's like having
most of a sand a storage area network so
you get most of the features you would
want from that and and by that i mean
you can take a snapshot of a disk
which makes a point in time copy without
slowing the disk down so you can make
backups of live systems uh anytime you
want and the other thing you can do
is you can take an existing disk and you
can just make it larger even while it's
connected to a machine i feel like
everybody's running a disk space at some
point i have a laptop and it it uh it's
run out of space and there's nothing i
can really do about it other than
plugging in an extra hard drive so
that's that's a feature that makes a lot
of sense to me
you said something earlier about um
snapshots and whatnot though and i'm
curious like what is the what's exciting
about that uh how does that become
usable in a production system so there's
the straight up um
so there's the straight up backup use
case um which i think is important but
then
um one of the
the big ways we kind of scale computers
these days is so it's vertical and
there's horizontal right so you know
vertical might be like making this
bigger like we talked about and then
horizontal is add more computers to the
mix doing it and so
if you
have
a computer that's set up the way you
want it to work you can take an
image you know a snapshot of that and
then you can make multiple copies that
make multiple images of that that are
running on multiple machines and have
them work as a group to to do the work
okay that is actually really cool
because you're going to get reliability
and consistency there you're not going
to get human errors
i am a huge fan of that um
is there is there anything else there
that you want to touch on uh because
like you said you're going to get
backups from this you're going to be
able to scale vertically and
horizontally from this
i i feel like those are some really big
benefits to disk and why they're useful
and even more useful than having a
physical
non-cloud native disk
so what do we need to follow up with in
the future we said cost you know i
missed cost and that's really important
so let's definitely have an episode on
cost
what else am i missing the whole episode
there makes sense and then i think as
you start you know with the scaling
stuff you get more moving parts right so
you you you go horizontal you'll have
more computers you'll have more disks
you you start need to think about kind
of networking patterns and so it's
useful to have some automation to set
that up and configure it in a consistent
way
yeah and i'm actually excited about that
because i'm a big fan of automating as
much as i can i make mistakes i don't
want to i don't want to risk it um brian
thanks again for just taking the time
i i gotta admit slowly
ah you're winning me over because love
it there seems to be a lot of a lot of
benefits um
thank you that's all for us this episode
if you're watching this at home
let me know anything that you think we
missed talking about or anything that
you thought was very cool i'm getting
one over right now are you with me or no
let us know in the comments below
[Music]
you